estas imágenes de propaganda muestran a
combatientes del grupo estado islámico
de jorasán su apodo tomado de una región
histórica del mismo nombre que incluye
partes de la actual afganistán y
pakistán ya en 2014 antiguos comandantes
talibanes afganos y paquistaníes
prometieron lealtad al difunto líder del
grupo estado islámico abu bakr al
bagdadí ya principios de 2015 el grupo
estado islámico reconoció oficialmente
la creación de su filial jorasán y el
estado islámico se estableció en
afganistán contando con los
decepcionados por los talibanes algunos
comandantes militares muy conocidos
juraron lealtad al estado islámico lo
que les dio un punto de apoyo en
afganistán
actualmente esta rama yihadista opera en
el norte de afganistán según un informe
de naciones unidas de julio el grupo
conserva entre 500 y 1.500 combatientes
de base aunque sus operaciones son en
gran medida clandestinas la filial del
estado islámico en afganistán compite
directamente con los talibanes grupos
que tienen importantes diferencias el e
ica se considera más extremos en
términos de teología y extra
en los últimos años los yihadistas de
jorasán han sido reprimidos por los
talibanes aún así han concebido llevar a
cabo atentados de gran repercusión en el
país atacaron la universidad de kabul y
la sala de maternidad de un hospital en
2020 mataron a 182 personas en el
aeropuerto de kabul en agosto durante la
evacuación de las tropas de
estadounidenses
creo que los talibanes van a tener las
manos llenas con él e ica y dejaron
salir a mucha de esa gente de las
cárceles y ahora van a poder cosechar lo
que sembraron leica tiene grandes
ambiciones y según los expertos de
seguridad el grupo debe ser tomado en
serio con la salida de las fuerzas
estadounidenses de afganistán los
yihadistas se esperan aprovechar el
momento y mostrar a los afganos que son
una alternativa viable al dominio
talibán